when i was running manhattan prep um i
stepped down as ceo to start adventure
for america in 2011
and i have to say the organization did
not skip a beat
and i thought to myself wow it turns out
i was not that important
and you know there was some part of me
that was a little bit uh crestfallen
where it's like oh i'll make myself
available to the incoming
executive director head of the company
or whatnot and you know what else
happens the person you bring in as your
successor never calls you or if they do
call you is just with a concrete ass
because it turns out they don't really
want your advice they want you to get
lost
[Laughter]
totally do the way that most people
operate in life and a lot of people
listening to this probably have been
through this like let's say that you
have a new head of a company the the
first thing people think to themselves
is how does this affect me
you know
and so then people are just like oh am i
gonna be okay and then as soon as you're
like yeah you're fine i'm like oh okay
you know who who's who's the new person
this person no like uh like most people
immediately are just like
okay as long as my stuff is more or less
stable like i'll just get used to the
new reality i think strong organizations
can do without the founder and i'm so
proud of the fact that
venture of america has been going strong
now for years without me
uh i think that actually is the highest
mark of entrepreneurship is that you can
build something and then step away and
then it thrives without you yes i do
liken it a bit to parenting it's like
you don't want a kid who [ __ ] needs
you
i mean yeah that's not a good parent day
like you know the kid gets to
um you know 25 and he's like hey you
know like
mom yeah like screwing this light bulb
for me or whatever like the thing is
you're like you know do it yourself
right so you want the org to be the same
way
[Music]
[Music]
this week on for the podcast we talk
about founder syndrome in the wake of
jack dorsey stepping down from twitter
omicron ominous
and also the politicization of the
economy the fact that people now have an
opinion about the economy based upon how
they feel about the party in power yeah
i know that's that's happening this week
on forward
[Music]
we are back on the forward podcast this
week who knows what the [ __ ] we're going
to talk about we're going to talk about
it first and then we'll do the intro
later
the magic just gonna let it the magic of
not so live entertainment gonna let it
take us where our hearts desire brother
happy uh hope your thanksgiving was good
man yeah it was great uh family
food
a lot of food
definitely the best holiday no pressure
you know no presents
yeah it was it was lovely yeah i hope
everyone had a wonderful thanksgiving
so news of the week
jack dorsey is stepping down as ceo of
twitter and then he's taking the next
step and leaving the board
about six months from now uh
unusual for someone to step away
fully
read his note on twitter about his
resignation
and i i need to backdrop this by saying
that we are friendly friends with jack
dorsey friend of the show friend of the
show yes you can look up
my convo with jack dorsey last year uh
to get a sense as to who he is i thought
that podcast interview with him which
was one of our highest rated episodes
was an unusual glimpse cause it's not
like jack ordinarily does interviews
like that ordinarily it's a different
type of environment
so i like jack i appreciate jack
i uh admire him i'm indebted to him
he's been one of the biggest champions
of universal basic income
and that includes supporting the cash
relief efforts of humanity forward
during the pandemic
so if you're looking for someone
uh who's somehow you know not uh
[Music]
not
friends with jack this is not the
like
not the cookie for the anti-jack takes
probably us we like jack yeah we we like
jack um and he's someone who just openly
came out and said look we're making
decisions that
we shouldn't be making and at this point
technology companies the government
media organizations and non-profits
should get together right and try to
establish some guidelines
i thought that was very reasonable
you know what's unreasonable now is that
our government is way behind the curve
and then foisting various decisions on
private enterprises saying hey do this
do that you screw this up frankly
there's no way to draw a line if you're
a twitter that's not going to piss
someone off
and then
the hearings are completely inane and
nonsensical i mean that they're like
legitimate issues um but jack's been one
of the good ones in my mind saying like
yeah there are legitimate issues and
let's try to get together on this
i have a certain level of empathy for
these tech founders
because they built something with a
great idea obviously and then
it becomes something that no one could
have ever ever fathomed and so they're
stuck with this okay what do we do with
this how do we monitor how do we i don't
want to use the word i mean sensor is
what's thrown around but how do you
navigate the
the hate and the love and the the free
for all that is the what the internet
was when they first started and still is
today
and
the government's been out to lunch doing
nothing what did you think i don't think
we ever talked about this what did you
think when they kicked trump off um i
don't have you ever had public thoughts
on that
i think at that point it was the right
move i mean he was legitimately
inciting
violence right uh and
lives were lost uh you know like what
was before
you'd consider it somewhat
political had kind of gone into another
area
uh and i will say that
the
world has been a little bit
less noisy and more lucid with
trump off of
the major social media platforms
um now there are people that will look
at that and and say oh that's the wrong
decision and censorship and freedom of
speech and the rest of it right um the
the thing that people don't understand
is that
the first amendment freedom of speech
says that government shall not abridge
people's freedom of speech
news flash twitter is not the us
government
twitter is
a private company
that can have terms of service and do
what it wants it's like if you went into
a restaurant and started doing things
that were against that restaurant's term
to terms of service i mean whatever it
is and they can be like hey get lost
and that's allowed and you can't be like
hey i can say whatever i want because of
the first amendment that's not the way
it works right it's like the
government's not supposed to abridge
your freedom
um but if a private firm makes a
decision that you're
not not
wearing i don't i was gonna joke saying
like wearing a shirt because that's what
i think of in the restaurant
it's like i'm not sure if there's a
wearing a shirt equivalent yeah wearing
a shirt like where it's like uh there's
like a you know you have a right to
bare your torso
[Laughter]
so so a private
firm making a decision like that
i thought was appropriate right if it i
mean if it was a comedy club where
people are like
i'm trying to get like a more accurate
analogy where the role of the
participants or the talent there is to
say whatever they want the comedy club
could kick someone out that's saying
something offensive right um that
crosses a line
yeah i mean hopefully that doesn't have
any comedy club i feel like comedy club
yeah i agree that's not the best
environment but maybe but that's the
point there probably is a line for
comedy clubs right where you're oh man
inciting violence and uh yeah i suppose
if you were just if if you were
legitimately inciting violence in the
country right
i think
i know it was january 6th that really
that really did it right i also want to
say too that
jack runs two major tech companies too i
mean that's the thing to know he also
runs square right yeah so
and either of those jobs is enormous
you know what i mean big jobs like
they're they're both
public companies worth tens of billions
of dollars have hundreds or thousands of
people working for them
touch millions of people
having any individual in charge of two
of those enterprises at the same time
strikes me as frankly kind of superhuman
now
there are other examples of this i mean
elon's running uh tesla and spacex and a
couple of other things right um so to
the extent that you are one of these
founders and you've managed to put
yourself in in that particular
position
i mean
i'm not intrinsically
uh my against that sort of arrangement
if that's you know the the best
approach i will say though that having
run various organizations it strikes me
as like a whole lot for
any individual it's a little bit like if
you're a sports fan where the nba has
done away with this
president role where you're both the gm
and the coach
because they've decided you know what
you should probably have two different
people doing those jobs
[Laughter]
so it's not like jack doesn't have a
massive set of responsibilities that he
immediately
is turning to i mean uh he's right now
dividing his time between these two huge
firms
i used to have a boss when i was at ubs
we used to um
he was
like a field guy used to manage it it
was it was wealth management so we
managed financial advisors and they were
managers of those financial advisors and
it treat up and there were seven
thousand of them um
so there's a lot of people to manage
plus their teams and all the employees
and all people look up to you and there
were certain roles he was hiring and
he'd be like yep that's a big job
and those level you'd still that person
only have a couple thousand finding a
couple it was a bit small but a couple
few thousand financial advisors and then
all the the managers that report up to
him or her
and even that was big so the concept to
me of and it's right what does a big job
mean it's taking all of your time you're
traveling probably a lot you've got a
lot of people depending on you their
livelihood mouths to feed all these
things your decisions affect the lives
of frankly millions if you do the
trickle-down so the concept being ceo of
two tech conglomerates is
mind-blowing to me um you probably have
to have really good people doing some of
the operational work and day-to-day
decision-making i could be wrong maybe
they are superhuman they do it
themselves but well i from my limited
exposure to jack i do get the sense that
he's extraordinary at streamlining
his uh responsibilities in time where he
i think he just goes in and focuses on
the most important things
and has excellent people around him
right um but that's from the outside
looking in right
um so i wanted to ask you about founder
syndrome because
um i come from
in the nonprofit social enterprise world
and you spent some time there too and in
that world it's um
great
and exciting young non-profits are so
founder driven because their job to just
exude the energy and optimism and raise
money and everybody who's donating to a
big nonprofit wants to meet the founder
so they end up being like the only
player in many ways you can't outsource
a lot of the founder role
um
and you end up treating the org a bit
like it's your child like it's your baby
or like a part of you and maybe that's
similar being treating like a child
did you i'm sure you felt this your own
way but what was that experience founder
syndrome wise adventure for america
because you eventually left and the org
is still thriving um what did you how
did you experience that
a friend said to me a while ago and he's
right nonprofits run on passion and so
when you're the founder you are exuding
passion for the mission
uh that's to by the way get people to
work with you too i mean not just donors
or supporters or board members or
partners yeah it's employees like who
the heck's going to join this firm and
you have to really
believe
um
i started adventure for america in 2011
and ran it for six years and so there
was a lot of love like you said it you
felt like you were the head of an
extended family
and it's very very difficult to leave
because you feel almost a sense of like
abandonment to your point
in my case i left to run for president
of the united states and i i i'm
actually going to share something um so
i ran an education company for a similar
length of time
uh
maybe five years
and
leaving that
firm was very very hard because i also
felt like the head of that household and
so i needed to do something very
purpose driven
in order to justify leaving frankly like
i i wouldn't have been able to
live with myself if i was just saying
like hey guys i'm leaving as head of the
company so i can
you know
uh chill out or find myself or any of
those things i mean you know nothing
against people who do that right
but i just would have felt like i was
shirking and so in my case i left to
start this non-profit that was going to
help create thousands of jobs and like
give rise to this culture of
entrepreneurship and so that that was
something that i could say and feel very
good about
and i felt the same way leaving venture
for america where it's like okay i'm
leaving to run for president on
universal basic kingdom and that was a
very
big noble somewhat unlikely mission
and and then so if someone adventure for
america was like okay andrew's doing
this i actually thought that my
presidential run was in some ways meant
to serve as an example for folks who are
in venture for america where it's like
okay someone can do something big
and ambitious
and
actually
succeed on some level
and i'll say to you zach that i felt
immense pressure
because
uh the folks adventure of america saw me
leave to run for president and then if i
fell flat on my face i'd i'd feel really
bad
because everyone was part of edge of
america i was like hey
you know our founder left to do this
stupid thing i mean if it was a flop so
that was one of the things that drove me
to to try and
uh make a mark was like oh man if i left
uh
vfa this org that i spent years building
uh to do something i'd better do it well
[Music]
we're all looking for better ways to do
the things we do every day and you know
what we do every day if we're healthy is
go number two hope you do it every day
and then afterwards if you're like most
of us
you use some toilet paper you wipe but
what if it didn't have to be that way
what if you could
make it cleaner with water
better for the environment more
effective more modern more european more
cosmopolitan
that's what tushy will help you do it's
a bidet that attaches right to your
toilet
at home
spray
and pat dry it installs in less than 10
minutes even if you don't know what
you're doing yeah believe it or not this
stuff now is available for all of us in
our home it saves money pretty quick
because that toilet paper adds up you
can give the gift of a clean bum to
yourself or your loved ones this holiday
season and get 10 off plus free shipping
right now at hellotushi.com
yang
that's
hellotushi.com for 10 off and free
shipping better ways to do things you do
every day that's what we're about
[Music]
i've seen this a lot so if you're the
founder of this org
and you're the passion you're growing it
you're hiring people
it's very very very difficult to leave
you were managed to leave with even
higher and let's call it different
ambitions you went from for-profit to
non-profit from non-profit to politics
like you're one of the probably one of
the only ones i've ever done it well
most of the time it's a really awkward
transition because let's say you've been
selling this we're going to cure
you know uh we're going to give drinking
clean drinking water to the entire world
and you've been selling this and
everybody's buying buying what you're
selling and then you leave
it's like you gave up right when in
reality you've been doing it for 10
years seven years like you may just want
a life change right and then the other
thing is if you're a really successful
charity
and you're raising tons and tons of
money you're now
at the upper echelons of society right
you're mingling with the world's richest
wealthiest most famous people and you're
not rich yourself and it's a little bit
of a
that is that is hard especially when
you're clearly um smart enough to make
money and smart enough to to be kind of
thriving in the capital society so i
don't know if you ever felt if that was
ever part of it or have you ever thought
about the the money aspect um well i i
made a comment that that's what
politicians feel where they're going to
talk about all those
rich people and then you're like i'm
just as important and smart and capable
as you are and then the rich people are
like yeah yeah you are hey let's cut you
in on this deal hey hey you'll do this
video yeah let's do it uh and one of the
mysteries of our time is how people are
getting so rich in office in dc you
notice that yeah it's like they go in as
relatively normal people making salaries
of x and then come back uh
multi-millionaires and you're like like
how the heck did that happen like i can
look up your salary
[Laughter]
it's either insider trading or advisory
shares on boards uh probably a combo
i don't know well but i have been in
these environments and there are very
wealthy people that do want to be your
friends and they do want to cut you in
on various things right uh and so i
think that's where it goes
you know you hear about politicians
being on boards and being in various
deals right um
and a lot of political figures
um
haven't necessarily
made money in business or or
uh right you know and so if you're
around
these donor types but you're right on
the non-profit side as well i knew a lot
of founders of non-profits who were
doing
the the right thing and then at some
point they'd look up and say wait this
isn't sustainable for me if i want to
have a family if i want to do this
um and that's a very very difficult
transition for a lot of people to make
i've you know the tough part too is if
you're the founder of a non-profit
you're not allowed to acknowledge that
in most environments like i was the head
of venture for america and i'd be
sitting with the head of another
non-profit and they would be talking to
me about how like hey i'm trying to
propose to to my girlfriend but i don't
think i can afford this and like i'm
worried that they're not going to um to
be able to envision a future with me
because we live in this small place and
you know like we're driving this used
car and like blah blah and i would hear
this stuff and frankly in my case would
just make me like go home and just be
grateful because in my case i'd at least
made some
money as a
um
private company ceo and an entrepreneur
before i decided to go nonprofit uh but
someone who just been in the nonprofit
world and and worked uh their hearts out
you know that they would be struggling
and then they wouldn't be able to say
that openly because oh by the way
they're supposed to be martyrs they're
supposed to be
driven by the work it's like the work is
the privilege
no
i'm not going to take this one step
further too i mean there are a lot of
creatives who are in a similar boat now
like you're about the art
and then you're not allowed to complain
if it's like hey you know i'm not making
much money here as a musician or
uh actor or
playwright or whatever the thing is yeah
so the the non-profit founder syndrome
is very very tough and very very real
i was extraordinarily fortunate that
there was an awesome
person ready to take on the ceo role as
i stepped away
i do remember going to my board in early
2017 saying hey guys i'm leaving to run
for president and the reactions as you
can imagine were all over the map
but they they got with the program
quickly where they were like andrew's
leaving and then they were like oh let's
figure out what the next era looks like
and
i'm happy to say that venture of america
has just continued to go on the couple
years after i left were actually some of
the best years so i used to joke that
you know i must have been holding it
back
we dan pilata uh is one of my favorite
he is a ted talk called uncharitable
he's a thought leader in this space he's
exceptional exceptional pub speaker but
one of the things he says is we have
a problem in the united states of
america
where people make a ton of money
doing good
we have a problem with that it's not
okay it's not acceptable but we have no
problem if you make a ton of money
doing bad doing terrible things like if
you frack your way to billions and
billions of dollars and destroy the
environment in the process we'll put you
on the cover of forbes we'll praise that
you're a billionaire like if you want to
run for president will tout you or media
or cover you like you're a superstar but
if you make a million dollars running
the c being the ceo of the boys and
girls club which is helping millions of
kids right if you streamline that triple
revenues and make a million dollars
compared to a billion we're talking
about
we'll literally crucify you and we have
i think in 2010 they got rid of the boys
and girls ceo was fired for
uh having a million dollar total
compensation and paying their executives
well even though their track record was
pretty great at the time
um
and now i
don't think
you know and no one wants their
donations going to pay for
andrew yang's yacht adventure for
america or something like that but
there's got to be a happy medium um
because in order to run anything any
talent i mean you got to have
incentivizing entrepreneur i don't know
i remember dan palotta ted talk too
where he was he was talking about how if
you went to a fancy business school and
your option was either
start a non-profit or make lots of money
and then join the board of a nonprofit
everyone would do the latter yeah and
then we praised that too it's like oh
it's on it's like smarter yeah um
because you know then you don't have to
actually make
massive financial sacrifices you just
give a little bit of money and then
you're there bossing around the person
who
actually will put your name on the door
right no executive director gets their
name on the door or the name on the
building uh it's usually the donor
yeah you and i lived versions of this
man people don't appreciate zach here
started a non-profit for underprivileged
kids saw a suit called suit up that's
been doing great work for a decade and
he managed to do that in addition to all
of his other stuff that was my um so we
talked about a bit but like one of the
things we had like the founder syndrome
of this is actually real where that
so when i joined the campaign
which was you and me and a couple of
others in 2018
um
i transitioned
sued up basilic gave the keys to a new
hire her name was lauren reilly and
she's exceptional um but it was hard for
me
to give
the ropes to someone to like let give
your it's like you're handing your kid
over you know um
and it was you i found myself like
biting my tongue a lot like don't do
that or do this or trying to give advice
or maybe i shouldn't have and it was it
was a good transition for us but did you
feel that when you left vfa or were you
able because president was so time
consuming able to just get cold turkey
and like good luck venture for america
well i've had a couple of experiences
here where when i was running manhattan
prep um i stepped down as ceo to start
adventure for america in 2011
and i have to say the organization did
not skip a beat
and i need you and i thought to myself
that's like oh like i'm important here
you know like i have a lot of
uh experience and relationships and like
uh the org did not skip a beat and so
the lesson i took from that is like wow
it turns out i was not that
important
and you know there was some part of me
that was a little bit uh crestfallen
where it's like oh i'll make myself
available to the incoming
uh executive director head of the
company or whatnot and you know what
else happens the person you bring in as
your successor never calls you or if
they do call you it's just with a
concrete ass because it turns out they
don't really want your advice they want
you to get lost
[Laughter]
totally do
so because i'd been through that
experience when i left venture for
america and i was a much more integral
part of venture for america than i was
manhattan prep even though i was the ceo
and you know president of manhattan prep
but i was more tied to the
uh life's blood of venture for america
but i still thought it's like you know
what they're going to be okay without me
and the way that most people operate in
life and a lot of people listening to
this probably have been through this
like let's say that you have a new head
of a company the the first thing people
think to themselves is how does this
affect me
you know
and so then people are just like oh am i
going to be okay and then as soon as
you're like yeah you're fine i'm like oh
okay
you know who who's who's the new person
this person no like uh like most people
immediately are just like
okay as long as my stuff is more or less
stable like i'll just get used to the
new reality
uh and
that that took again a bit of adjustment
because you're like oh like isn't it
important that it be me and then it's
like not really
so uh having been through that with
one company and then a non-profit i
think strong organizations can do
without the founder and i'm so proud of
the fact that
venture of america has been going strong
now for years without me
uh i i think that actually is the
highest mark of entrepreneurship is that
you can build something and then step
away and then it thrives without you yes
i do liken it a bit to parenting it's
like you don't want a kid who [ __ ]
needs you
you know what i mean yeah that's not a
good parent day like you know the kid
gets to
um you know 25 and is like hey you know
like
yeah like screwing this light bulb for
me or whatever like the thing is you're
like you know do it yourself right so
you want the org to be the same way
[Music]
we all have doubts and deficiencies
where you're like oh man am i good at
that thing and one of the ways that you
can give yourself confidence is
skillshare i always feel better when i
actually know what i'm doing
[Laughter]
skillshare is a leading way to learn new
skills online they're a sponsor of our
podcast and i'm thrilled for it i
actually know
one of the co-founders who was genuinely
driven by helping people learn and today
you can take classes and everything from
how not to have a printer go off on your
i'm sorry i think it was away from this
printing and stuff
i wonder how long this is gonna go on
for
oh it's over sweet
you can learn design interior design
photography skills email marketing how
to be a better podcaster i mean
literally that's a thing a skill share
pretty much anything you can envision
that people are interested in and want
to get better at it's available to you
on skillshare and it's incredibly
expensive an annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month explore your
creativity at skillshare.com yang and
get a one month free trial of premium
membership you know you can see if it
works within one month that's one month
of a premium membership at
skillshare.com yang thanks for
sponsoring the episode skillshare we're
glad you do
[Music]
uh it's tough to try to cultivate a
new ceo or leader
um and
now that's something that i think if
you're the head of an organization you
should always be um
be keeping an eye out for it's like okay
is there someone who could actually
make me irrelevant yeah so our ceo now
lauren
has been remarkable zoodup's like
completely
better in every way right um and and
we're now gonna we're gonna be a million
dollar organization next year i thought
about the times fantastic i feel like a
proud point proud parent um i do like to
to our own horn a bit or anyone's horns
like the the a good a sign of good
leadership is that when the founder
leaves the leader leaves the org can
still not only exist but thrive um
and that it's set up um it's it's credit
to the culture of the the idea or
whatever it is so that was
as as painful as that was like for me it
was painful to see suit up doing well
and i was like completely worthless in
many ways uh but it's also now it's a
point of pride right like a little time
and i'm sure you feel that same way too
we're like
uh vfa still doing great you know i i
have a number of marriage jokes here
zack where it's like you know
of course i can take direction i'm
married but you know like there's like a
degree of
uh acknowledgement of your own uh
extraneousness
which i also think
comes along with people i said that to
my dad i was like is the point when men
get married
they just have someone if they get
married to a woman like you just have
someone the rest of your life that just
points out your flaws that's just there
for you to just to say hey you got a
gray hair hey you've got xyz wrong with
you is that is that what is that it it's
not quite like that it's not as mean
it's at least for me and evelyn it's
like evelyn is aware of things i'm not
aware of and sees things i'm not aware
of and so it's just like hey do this pay
attention to this do this do this and
you're like okay okay yeah yeah yeah and
and
you know that that person is correct uh
a whole lot
[Laughter]
it's also different when you like carly
is is smarter than me so that's like
another like i can't win an argument
with her unless i'm really really right
but other than that like should just
wordsmith their way out of whatever
argument and so that's like a whole
another can of worms too i am
shrug um
anyway
i would do recommend marrying or getting
dating and marrying someone smarter than
you it's a
um because if you win every argument
that's not fun either you know oh yeah
you know ideally you have someone who's
like a like a
partner to you where you know like you i
mean certainly for me it's like uh i
want to share this joke too where
i talk to my boys about how they should
appreciate evelyn so much because she's
such a great mom and i say if it was up
to dad
um your companion would be
an inflated balloon um called inflato
and then every time you needed something
it would be like talk to inflato and
then plato would just sit there silent
i'd be like that's how you'd learn to
just do [ __ ] for yourself like so
you know so
[Laughter]
so now every once in a while the eye
household i just yelled inflato
and then the boy started laughing
because it's just like well but i say it
when they're frankly being like kind of
um
needy or whiny
uh you know when they're they're just
like hey this happened hey help me with
this i'm just yelling plato so there's a
show a new show on netflix i'm not gonna
recommend it but if you guys are really
desperate for content i'll you know
throw this on your list it's called
inside job it's an animated show about
like making fun of all the conspiracies
in the united states they're like the
deep state but there's one guy who's
like a super scientist genius
um it's kelly slater is the voice of it
and he
didn't want to deal with his daughter so
he just made her like a giant bear robot
called barrow and that's what that
reminds me of yeah yeah to give her hugs
play-doh my kid's like totally
traumatized from this um
the other thing it reminds me of
is on the campaign
where like one of the hardest parts in
the campaign running for president was
like
things would happen in hq
and
for me like learning
one what mattered at all like whether
those things in hq actually mattered and
two what are they matter enough to bring
up to you right and i did not always get
this right i mean we didn't always get
this right we're learning as we go to
the beginning but there was one time
i'll never forget this i told i brought
something up and you just looked at me
and go zac here's what i want you to do
i want you to tell whoever brought this
up in hq
to go put a mannequin
in the closet in the back corner of our
headquarters
and i want that mannequin to have a sign
and every time
things like this happen i want to go
check the mannequin when they go check
the mannequin that'll open the closet
door and they're going to walk in
they're going to see the mannequin
they're going to see the sign and the
sign is going to say
it doesn't [ __ ] matter
you remember this oh yeah of course
this is like a leadership tactic of
yours does this happen in prior
organizations
well i mean you know it's it's just true
some of the time yeah just get
themselves so my my little boys tend to
get themselves into a tizzy over stuff
that you know frankly that didn't merit
and there were some people on hq that
had the same tendency so it would
consult the sign campaigns are hard too
because everything's happening at once
it was not not a knock on anyone because
it's um you know um
there's a lot of stuff on campaigns that
are just like table stakes and so
so it's a zero-sum game right you either
need to you're getting on the ballot or
you're not or you're either you know
we're knocking on doors today or not or
that sort of thing but when you're in
that moment it doesn't feel like a zero
to one game it feels like the whole gray
in between matters and that's like
probably the hardest well you know it's
tough i mean it's tough when you're
uh disconnected from the candidate or
field and you're like oh they should be
doing this they should be doing that and
then in the field you'd be like hey guys
like we kind of have our hands full yeah
that don't work you know doing things
and your suggestion by the way
is not good it's terrible we tried that
please stop asking we tried that four
weeks ago and then abandoned it
immediately
that is the hard part and it's it was
harder for us too because you're not
you have robot tendencies in many ways
but you're not a political robot in the
sense that you'll go up and just read
the script and not think twice about it
right like i couldn't yeah the comms
team be like all right andrew's got to
say this and i'll be like
you know i try to massage it a bit like
don't you gotta give it andrews i'll
give it to andrew and you're like what
is this this is trash we're not doing
this and it's like all right like
uh because you're a human you know there
are but there were candidates and i was
somewhat jealous of them from a
campaign manager standpoint they would
just read the script um and a lot all of
those lost frankly um
and uh the best candidates particularly
in the top three or four
or let's go to top six to seven usually
thought for themselves even joe like he
wasn't he wasn't known for gas because
he would go off script um and sometimes
that's when he was great too
anyways we somehow got
jack dorsey has sparked a whole number
of conversations so thank you jack
appreciate that uh good luck at square
jack good luck good luck it's helping
all the small businesses thank you for
supporting me forward thank you for your
money
thank you for creating an addictive app
uh
for better for worse all right oh we i
you know i i should say uh certainly the
yang gang owes twitter a great deal i
think so twitter
um
is a tough place
but twitter definitely helped fuel
the rise of our campaign i'd like to
think that we're still a very very
positive force on twitter
uh so yeah thank you for that too i mean
that's the thing about these tech apps
right the
the upside the good coming out is
remarkable right uh and it is kind of on
the government to
help them
mitigate the bad right um
speaking of mitigating the bad
omicron i say that right yes
omicron coved variant this is variant
number god knows what
uh i think omicron is the 15th greek
letter in the alphabet i have no idea
but they've skipped a few they skipped c
the one that was x i z g chi c i'm
terrible greek letters guys don't quote
me on this um
they skipped that because i don't think
it'd be good i think i mean there's
rational reasons i think um
anyway they skipped a few yeah i don't
know if it's the 15 variants yeah i
don't know um new york city is now
requiring they're strongly recommending
to wear masks indoors in public places
which sucks um
i want to ask you andrew
do you think this thing is ever going
away
there is going to be
a push and pull
between humans and
the coronavirus variants
out into the foreseeable future
and i would measure that future in
months and years
so anyone who
imagined that hopefully we'd be done
with this thing
there are a number of reasons why we
will not be done with this thing the
most obvious are that one there's a
significant body of humans around the
world that are not vaccinated and
they're they're ample
places for this to mutate uh number two
is that the world is now interconnected
so guess what i'm sure omicron's already
alive and well in the united states sure
i mean i think canada just reported a
case i mean the odds of this being
contained to where it was reported we're
recording this monday this airs thursday
uh there'll definitely be a case by then
right yeah that would probably be a case
for that time of stairs yeah and then um
there's also like a a critical mass of
unvaccinated people here in in the us uh
and so you put all this together and the
odds of this
coming here to the us and being a
significant factor are very very high
and oh by the way if it's not omicron
it'll be the next one greek letter after
that the greek letter after that
um so
what we should be doing in in my mind is
uh
accepting that this is the new way of
things and the new reality uh and then
try to mitigate and but live our lives
but by the way we shouldn't let it
obsess us we shouldn't let let it keep
us from living our lives uh you know
that like there's there's a risk reward
ratio to everything
and the just the risk is going to be
with us for a while um but we should not
try and say to ourselves that like the
risk is
uh total to a point where it completely
changes our behaviors or our
relationships
ah it's um
well the other thing just add on that is
that
even if you are vaccinated people are
still you're still getting it and some
people are still dying from the va the
vax is doing good but it's not it's not
it's not full proof at least right now
right yeah i mean that's
what the concern is about omicron is
that it's got a bunch of mutations that
would make it likely to infect someone
who has certain antibodies based upon
existing vaccines now you can have an
omicron specific vaccine that gets
developed and then
that would be more helpful
so that's what they're going to work on
right now uh and
we can look forward to all going out and
getting that vaccine incidentally if
you're listening to this
i think that vaccines are a great idea
and if you're still
not vaccinated
please do strongly consider doing so
because it'll protect you
hey you might even make out well in the
sense that maybe you'll get like the
cool new omicron
[Laughter]
or you'll get some vaccines that are you
know like a little bit more
um developed or with it who knows but
you know i think vaccines are good
a good counter measure just for your
personal safety and
health
so i was looking at the the graph this
is the new york times take that really
well but the graph of case new cases of
coven since since it started let's call
it march 2nd of 2020
do you know when the peak of covet cases
were
uh
probably early last year it was early it
was late 2020 and then the actual peak
is january 9th 2021 early this year um
so it wasn't in march what i thought was
that that was the spike the actual spike
at least according this like if you just
google covet cases and what they're from
the new york times
it seemed like such an outbreak and it
was because we were not prepared for it
um
but we still and then the second we
still are getting a ton of cases post
vaccine and post or i guess this isn't
post vaccine but um in the winter months
and then the second peak was actually
this summer um
of this year of 2021 uh in august in
early september um
so cove it's still real i think it's
frustrating i think it's frustrating for
all of us so this is the nuance right um
i'm curious to take their response to
this so on one hand cove it's bad it's
deadly people are dying they're getting
really sick
um
it's been politicized the vaccine itself
has been politicized that is not fun um
on the other hand
this is where my question is coming like
we're not a
we're not a communist society we believe
in capitalism so if people want really
to live in the united states you have to
work generally speaking and if they want
to work they got to go outside and they
have to work with others and that risks
more coveted exposure right
so
those who can move to like adjust this
lifestyle i think have right there are
plenty of folks who had the means that
and those who wanted to were afraid of
covid they had and they could move they
have they moved to suburbs they moved to
places without door um less people more
outdoor space but many have not or
cannot um
so my question i really want to talk
about the policy ideas here given that
this i think you just kind of outlined
this is probably our new normal for the
next five years like maybe that's too
far but
it's not great several years and several
yeah a number of years um if this
thing's going to keep mutating and we
all keep
getting sick
what are the policy ideas
i have a couple but what what do you do
if you're in charge to navigate this
because i think what we're doing right
now is unsustainable where it's like
don't mask up no no mask up we gotta
freak out like people are like oh we're
coming back and we're not coming back
like i think i don't know i don't have
bigger policy ideas that
navigate this new normal
well i i heard one thing that was not
great which is that apparently there are
issues of confidence with the cdc not
just in the public
but um
in the government yeah but they don't
want to turn the cdc into a punching bag
and so you're looking at it being like
oh you know but unfortunately public
confidence has already been
shaken so if you make various
recommendations
it's uh you know it's tough as you're
describing it's like wait what did you
say what like what did you say last time
yeah um so the the thing we have to
acknowledge is that people are human uh
people have limited uh ability to absorb
different messages and and guidance and
and the rest of it uh and so we should
set out some broad principles around
uh who you are what your vulnerability
level is uh and take it from there
in my opinion
um
so if you're a normal person
uh you should
expect that you know getting vaccinated
is a good idea and that if you're
vaccinated there'll be some risk
associated with certain activities now
if you're not a vulnerable population
that risk will probably not be
um
no
anything you can't recover from i will
say i have friends and family members
who have had long covid um and it is a
beast oh man horrible yeah like it's
it's terrible and they will recover i
most people know i had coveted and so
i recovered fully
there was a period when i was short of
breath afterwards when i was like oh
this had better go away please let this
go away yeah um and then it did go away
and i was very very thankful
but you know i i know people who've
still been struggling with it
um i attended a memorial service of uh
someone's mother who died of
breakthrough covet i mean that was
freaking terrible and there are times i
look at my mom who's in her 70s i'm just
like well i mean she's been vaccinated
but you don't want
you know anything to break through
um
so you want to be accepting of the
limitations and fallibility of humans
and then lay out a number of things that
can be done that could genuinely
mitigate uh the the harm so if you are
in a particular environment i'll give an
example i went to a dave chappelle show
the other day
concert and then they tested the heck
out of us on the way in um and i thought
that was fine you know and then anyone
who was in there literally got a test
and you stood there for 10 minutes while
they gave you the result and be like
negative and so then you so then you
were with a bunch of people where you
had a fairly high confidence level that
they were all negative um i think that's
a fine type of ongoing precaution right
um and then there's that
accepted level of risk that we all
probably need to start accepting is that
kova is a thing but we're not going to
sit at home all day so we're still going
to go to sporting events so to go to
concerts and restaurants and
um that should be the public policy
guidance it's like look there is risk
but you can't eliminate the risk you can
mitigate it you can do various things
and so that that should be the guidance
[Music]
this is a tough time for just about
everyone but you should not take it
lying down you should do something about
it and one way you can do something
affirmative that is sure to help your
mental health and your day-to-day
happiness is betterhelp.com
your friends and family are not equipped
to listen to you vent all the time and
you feel bad if you're a conscientious
person you feel bad after
approximately one day of venting your to
your loved ones so who should you talk
to a professional licensed therapist who
is there to meet your needs you can
schedule them on demand this is not
self-help this is better help thrilled
to have them sponsor the podcast
thrilled to send our listeners their way
because this stuff works shocker talking
to a therapist is a good thing and
better help is the way to do it that
fits in with your lifestyle and your
budget i want you to start being happier
today and as a listener you'll get 10
percent off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health you
do not need to be sad and take it lying
down that's betterhelphelp.com
yang get yourself some help your loved
ones will be glad you did
[Music]
so
all right a couple
policy suggestions on your thoughts on
is there a place so one of the things
you suggested on climate change was to
move folks to higher ground and press
gave us some [ __ ] for that and now
they're suggesting it themselves here we
are um
is i mean this is ridiculous but i like
talking about really ridiculous ideas um
is there a way to move vulnerable
populations outside of vulnerable areas
and is that worthwhile for the
government to spend money on right so
vulnerable populations being one
older senior citizens who are in
highly urban areas that want to but
cannot afford to move folks that are
in a or maybe immunocompromised or
vulnerable but in a
close living space or something like
that where they could they are they can
be gainfully employed but would rather
do it in a less populated
urban center um
is that something we could do or like or
is that just something the government
can never execute and this idea in
practice would be a hot mess
well you referred earlier to the fact
that a lot of people have been making
various decisions
already yeah i i mean people know that
i'm all for putting money to people's
hands i'd be for putting money into
people's hands and then letting them
make a call yeah
okay well that answer my question way
simpler than i thought yeah you're right
though um you could say you could do
something like that like look here's
your moving stipend everyone you can do
whatever you want but from now but then
we're reopening the economy so if you're
not the situation this is money it needs
to be used for xyz i don't know or um or
we recommend but you do what you want
with it i think the economy is going to
be
open
for
the foreseeable as well yeah i think in
part because and this is the politics of
it
where
uh
shutting the economy down on behalf of
kovid is a political loser
and i think politics unfortunately are
so prevalent today
that
democrats are going to want to avoid
that as a step so i don't think that's
going to be in the
main conversation
so this is my next
kind of concept like is it just live and
let live then this is what florida has
been doing they're like we take care of
our most vulnerable but the reality is
we're not closing down the economy
because it's impossible and there's too
many businesses you'd hurt they're
already going to be hurt because people
can't like people are reluctant to go
outside
we can't hand-strung them or hamstring
them anymore
um
live on that live like this is these are
the risks that we have this is our new
normal republican state or governors
have been doing this to
frankly
like ignore the mainstream press that's
hammered them like they're they're still
winning their elections and they're
staying in power um and with higher or
decent approval like desantis say we
want about them as a proofreading
florida like fiber last check check
pretty good is that where we're going
like is that are you gonna see the left
start to be more live and let live or is
this uh i think that it's their people
are going to have uh
more
forgiving attitude because of the
fatigue factor uh i do i think uh and
also the politics like if you poll
people and say hey where's covid in your
issue set it used to be number one now
it's nowhere near number one
uh for for
uh better for worse i mean politics is
driving a lot of things nowadays so i i
don't think you're going to see people
um go as hard
and you know who i feel really bad for i
feel really bad for the healthcare
workers yeah because i know folks who
are in these settings and they say look
no one's talking about it but my
hospital's overrun like like my
colleagues are quitting
like uh my friends are all traumatized
i'm traumatized like you hear that and
you're like oh no
and sometimes it's in environments where
it's like i don't even know that kovid
was ripping through that community in
that way yeah um so the the suffering is
happening in those
environments in those facilities
regardless of whether the press makes a
big deal out of it or not
i feel bad for anybody working in
restaurants right now
or bars because you have to wear a mask
in mostly states so you're like this
faceless servant
that you can't really interact with
because they have a mask and i can't
always hear them but the people in there
don't have to wear a mask which
to me i guess it's uh well you're eating
in a restaurant so you're not wearing a
mask out but but like but yeah i don't
have to wear a mask if i walk in or
anything either
um but i don't know that's why i think
those jobs are already hard and then to
be kind of
like othered in that way you know where
they're so
it feels so separate i guess um i don't
know it's a less enjoyable experience
you can't get to know your waiter in my
opinion maybe i'm just a
awkward dad joke type that like to make
friends the waiter last thing i want to
touch on uh your conversation with derek
monday
talking about and it's kind of related
to this where the economy itself is now
political and you wrote an email on this
and we thought we touched on it oh my
gosh guys i i think this is one of the
most important ideas i've run across in
quite some time yeah and it is scary as
[ __ ]
it's that you know you imagine that that
two parties are at least kind of
uh
contesting various
um ideas as to how to drive the economy
forward like how to make our lives
better but it turns out that at this
point your opinion on how the economy is
is contingent upon how you feel about
the party in power
and so if you missed it
when i sat down with derek thompson and
he pointed out this stat to me so the
university of michigan has been running
consumer confidence surveys for years
and decades
and there has always been some
split between how
democrats and republicans have perceived
the economy but that split has grown
into a gulf the biggest gulf ever
recorded where right now
democrats
who are asked about the economy say it's
going great
uh and then republicans are like oh it's
terrible and there's a 49 point gap
in this scale democrats are plus 49
republicans like terrible independents
somewhere in between independents i
think are a little bit closer to
democrats i can pull the numbers up okay
okay so the numbers from the university
of michigan
the democrats are at 88.4
republicans at 37.8 for a record
difference of 49 points independents
were at 70 so a bit closer to democrats
but not nearly as high so that plus 49
is the biggest gap in recorded history
of the university of michigan consumer
service the gap of who thinks the
economy is doing well yeah this actual
question yes
and
and so then you think okay well maybe
democrats just live in flourishing areas
on the coast blah blah but it turns out
that the gap in october 2019 the second
biggest ever recorded was republicans
at 119
democrats at 71.6
and independence at a hundred so
republicans were plus 47 in october of
2019. now think about october 2019 who's
in charge donald trump
so when donald trump is president the
republicans are like things are great
and democrats are like oh things suck
and then it switches and now it's like
and you know why this is i mean here's
the working theory i have as to why this
is that if you turn on fox news right
now what do you see
record inflation
people spat democratic leadership bad
democratic leadership and then you get a
call from the university of michigan
being like hey how's things going you're
like oh they're terrible
you know and and if you turn on uh the
news on the other side they'll be like
oh there's some inflation but it's
supply chain disruptions and it's going
to ease and you know the
markets are good and you know like the
economic performance so like we're
getting fed alternate versions of
reality now that are so powerful that
they actually have overridden any kind
of day-to-day exposure to the economy in
terms of your perception of how things
are going
that this is some dark [ __ ] because it
means that the parties aren't even going
to have to pretend to argue to
compete on policy it's literally just
whose narrative is stronger and a
journalist in politico in 2020 michael
grunwald wrote there is a line of
thinking that america has entered a kind
of postmodern political era where the
appearance of governing is just as
politically powerful as actual governing
because most americans now live in
partisan spin bubbles that insulate
insulate them from facts on the ground
that's awful
and i quoted this in my book because i
thought it was such a powerful idea
where it's like hey it turns out that
actual policy is immaterial it's just
how do i make you feel
how are the aligned media organizations
broadcasting how you should feel
about the economy
um so this is scary [ __ ] this is a very
very dystopian and derek also was
frightened by it because plus 47 plus 49
based upon party what derek said was
that i don't even need to ask you about
what you think about the economy i can
just ask you how you feel about joe
biden
and if you like joe biden you'll be like
demo like economy great and if you don't
like joe biden you make economy terrible
[Music]
the internet right now
gives us all
and now particularly the younger
generations who was growing up with it
in their dna in a way right part of who
their personalities
it gives us all
essentially
whatever we want whenever we want it
like not everything but it's getting in
that place right whether it's i want
food on a man i want clothes on demand i
want to watch this video i watch cat
video like what like whatever i love
it's my human instinct and normally
that's in my opinion that's bad for
uh let's call it human morality and
behavior in the sense that most humans
like patience is a good virtue i think
the single biggest determinant in your
success in life is your ability to delay
gratification yeah it's the uh what is
it the marshmallow test yeah which is
one reason why i get so irritated on my
kids because they they they fail the
mushroom yeah they're very bad at this
sorry man you got time though they're so
young
uh the marshmallow test apparently i
guess it's for kids though yeah that's
indicative
anyway continue um i'm sure most of the
youth in america are failing the
marshmallow test right now and tough to
blame them because as you'd said on the
trail parents are outgunned um great
parenting i mean the only way to be a
truly great parent i guess is to keep
the kids away from the internet and this
have it whenever you want and that's
almost impossible nowadays too
so
my point is if that's the trend we get
whatever we want when we want it
whatever we want when we want over and
over and over it probably isn't going to
change like i mean my question for you
is like play that out and what does it
look like it probably looks like i mean
we're talking about 10 50 100 years from
now
people start to join their own virtual
governments
because that's what they want when they
want it their virtual societies their
their new friends and um for only people
that agree with them because that's what
they want when they want it like what
do and do businesses and brands and
companies start catering to these like
niche
personality types where joe biden is
king and donald trump's a devil and vice
versa on the other end and that and it's
gonna be wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i've got it i'm just trying to
play it out i've got it i've got it you
know how there was a joke it wasn't even
a joke i think when donald trump stopped
um being president where they were just
gonna build him a new oval office in
florida and then he was just gonna
govern from there yeah there was a joke
they're building in mar-a-lago or
whatever yeah
um we what we should do is we should
just have different versions of reality
that i can broadcast to people you know
i was just thinking to myself like how
could you get everyone to think the
economy is great just like just to have
two white houses
it does have like here's your reality
you happy they're like yeah yeah
yeah my neighbor's not that bad
i mean is it i mean this is
i mean maybe it's that level propaganda
to own order to do it i don't know but
pl my what's my fear is like how this
place why stop at two why not have five
not five twenty yeah and if you're
talking about
you know i think i want to do some more
research on our takes we haven't given
you our takes on web3 and the metaverse
so for you crypto nerds and i say nerds
as if it's not going to be mainstream
sooner or later um but for those of you
who are passionate about that i think we
we will dive in but not in this episode
but i think
if this new virtual world start becoming
a thing and if that's where facebook's
going um and black mirror episodes
become real life where you can just
upload your subconscious to different
parts of reality um
why not i don't know um
like we just force ourselves to make
this reality so terrible and that's
where it goes well i made this argument
in the war on normal people i said
billions of dollars going to be spent on
making these virtual worlds that are
extraordinarily enticing and pleasant
and the real world is going to get less
and less pleasant uh you know this is
before kovit and the rest of it that's
true uh and so which do you think is
going to win over time
and uh i i thought it was obvious that
eventually a lot of people are going to
be plugged into virtual worlds um
because the virtual world can be
whatever you want
you know the president can be whoever
you want maybe i mean to this point it
turns out that how you feel about who's
in power apparently like really affects
how you think that everything is going
uh so i i think your
vision is well taken zack it's that like
you know why do i care who's in that
white house when i can just put the
goggles on and then i got a new one
and
if the only thing that really matters in
that equation in that scenario is that
you're buying more bounty paper towels
on amazon or buying whatever hyper tar
you know like you're still consuming
in the attention economy then it will
happen right like i you know well this
is one very compelling reason too why
when people are like oh i don't pay
attention to politics it's entirely
rational
it's like if you pay a lot of attention
to politics it can depress you it can
infuriate you it does not can it's
statistically proven to lower your
happiness by like eight to eleven
percent yeah so people like oh i just
don't pay attention to that [ __ ] it'll
be like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
smart smart that's why a lot of people
don't pay attention politics like you
yeah
he's just kind of trolling everybody
yeah
well i mean for for for me too it's like
i pay attention to this stuff but one of
the things i really try and do
is not let it affect my mood yeah which
is you know like
it's not always easy
but and i think that's one of the things
about forward too which is like look
we're lucid we're rational we just don't
want to let this stuff
uh make me sad and mad and turn me
against other people uh and
generally uh be distraught
um you know which which is a highly
unusual approach to politics because the
most effective
emotions right now people can use on you
are fear and anger
and so if we're not trying to make you
afraid or angry though i will say there
are times when i do get angry at just
how ridiculous our system is and how
dysfunctional it all is and
um the incentives
around polarization are so strong like
the billions and billions of dollars and
like we have to go create our own
marketplace
around votes and media
and donors
uh
like your billion dollar marketplaces on
either side of you and then you're going
to try and create this new one
which by the way is totally vital and it
turns out that
you know 62 percent of americans want
some version of it and 44
uh you know would love to have
another
um
tent to rest under
uh so but it turns out that those people
are disproportionately
uh smart enough to stay the [ __ ] away
from politics
like that that's like the great irony of
it yeah
the fear i have on the metaverse
um
we will dive in more on this but it's
like
if capitalism and the markets are
untethered and just able to build this
you know with no government anything
you know they'll build it you know it'll
happen
like i mean they'll find a way to make
vr better and like i mean it's not a
matter of if it's when right um and i
still like the world we live in i know i
mean there's plenty of people who don't
i mean that's um
maybe part of what's driving it um
but uh i still think what we got's worth
saving uh i know you do too i'd much
rather invest in trying to make the real
world more
pleasant and harmonious and habitable
rather than head to the virtual world
try and make one up yeah yeah though the
virtual world is going to exist it's
going to be real uh you know we have to
try and make it as good as it can be
um but between those two
priorities certainly the real world is a
lot more important in my opinion amen i
don't
want ready player one
we're heading to ready player one yeah
we're very good enough
uh
all right let's talk about something
positive before we rap
what do you what's making you happy this
week
uh
i had a wonderful holiday
uh
i'm actually going to throw out
something that that uh
the idea for and i hope that listeners
find this interesting
so um i'm considering co-authoring a
political thriller about 2024
that's going to try and forecast some of
the likely snares of course you'd
fictionalize it and you know change
names and like smash some characters
together um but i i think this could be
a public service and fascinating because
if if you look at what's going to happen
it's not going to be great so we might
as well start trying to play it out
i kind of want to play it out for myself
so if you're interested
in a
novel political thriller like this uh
you know like i might be trying to bring
it to you i don't know if that's fun i
love that andrew yang the political
thriller writer
i hope it is
somewhat i hope it's almost as good as
your first thriller concept
which is blood caucus
which uh i think we've talked about on
this podcast uh
yeah so blood clothing is our first
concept so if you like this you like his
book there's a movie idea where
um it was a horror movie set in iowa and
the presidential candidates get killed
one by one yep um which would be a great
[ __ ] movie i think it'd be a
hilarious movie judd aptow if you listen
to this i think he's got your name
written all over it um so blood caucus
is one thought 2024 the novel be another
uh yeah like you know always exciting
things uh
and with a purpose behind them it's good
fun here at forward uh i love that and
on a more fun note the buffalo bills
play the new play the new england pa new
england patriots monday night football
in buffalo i'm going let me just say
this i talk about bills all the time in
here but i can feel like i have a
specific time to talk about it right now
because everyone hates the patriots and
so we're all buffalo bills fans america
this monday and i'll be there in person
it's going to be 20 degrees outside and
probably
sleeting or whatever it's going to do in
lake near lake erie but go bills screw
the pats
i'm excited anyway that's to get me
happy that's why i need the real verse
not the metaverse because
i gotta watch my bills in real life you
know
yes let's go real world
all right guys we love you
thank you for tuning in we'll see you
monday
[Music]
you